there it is
the inn of the giggling donkey
paladin are you sure the bard is hiding
out in there that's what twitter says
carrier raven butters so sorry that's
what the carrier raven says
craig and token guard the back door
butters kenny sir douchebag
let's go inside
stay closer douchebag the end of the
giggling donkey harbors the scum of
alzheimer
a glass of middleweight please no
needlewine today only fairy ale
a pound of faerio then
so has um anyone seen the bard lately
a cup of ferry isn't much if not
accompanied by some bardic poems and
songs
sure he's here all right he's got a room
down in the cellar ah
and i shall pay handsomely for his
services
sir douchebag butters douchebag go down
and flush him out
princess kenny and i will be waiting
here to murder him remember the bard can
use songs to enchant don't let him get
to you
be
[Music]
you think the bar's really down here
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
i think i hear him hello
[Music]
oh jesus it's the bird
prepare for battle weaklings elves fall
in
douchebag it's a trap you should have
never come here
humans i am a level 10 bod and with my
loot i shall power up my elven guards
with magical songs of enchanted
with magical songs with magical songs
magical songs have been changing me me
with magical songs
magical songs have been changing me
magical songs of enchantment
there once was a maiden from stoneberry
hollow
she didn't talk much but boy did she
swallow
stop it
by the hammer of better
i have a nice lamps that she set upon
the maiden from stoneberry who is also
your mom oh
you're not waiting on me are you
[Music]
nobody once was a likes me stoneberry
hollow
she didn't talk much but boy did she
[Music]
swallow
so
yes
[Music]
but i have a nice lance that she set up
one
the maiden from stoneberry who is also
your mom
wow what a butt kicking i'm a lot more
experienced now
get down there and finish them off i
will protect the stick of truth
don't prisoner you're going
out
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
hey sir douchebag up here
i'll handle this
i think it might be broken maybe i
should take a look at it
[Music]
[Music]
whatever
oh no we're locked in we could be stuck
in here forever
my ankle
happy to heal the thief but i need your
commandment lord that's how the game
works
is ours
[Music]
your word is the command my lord
die [ __ ]
your word is the commandment
i'm going to beat the [ __ ] out of you
wherever you go
[Music]
come on
[Music]
we'll see if it works
[Music]
uh
ah
your word is the command my lord
[Music]
[Music]
ow ow
yes sir here's a buddy
thank you double palleted my world is
healed can you get us upstairs i think
they locked us out
nothing a level 12 thief can't take care
of you guys go ahead
come on let's get out of here
for the okay
that came from the kitchen
come on in the kitchen we gotta help him
i'll get you back
die wizard
this elf is gonna [ __ ] you up you're a
douche
[Music]
you asked for it new kid
no no no no
ugh
ow
[Music]
ow jeez
by the hammer of betters
[Music]
that was the most perfect throw i've
ever seen i hope they're just sleeping
your word is the command my lord shall i
heal the king my lord
or maybe let him suffer just a little
bit more
i'm not dead you can't loot me yet your
word is the commandment lord
you're not getting past that [ __ ]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
um
your word is the commandment
yes sir lock it up buddy
his powers were too strong the bard
he's up in one of the rooms
they took princess keaney they took her
upstairs i'm sure they're gonna rape her
don't let them rape princess kinney
i'm not dead you can't loot me yet the
wizard king is done for
take out the new kid while i go upstairs
and make contact with the king of elves
we should give this in a really mean
online review after we're done killing
everybody
use your magic on the front door juice
bag
hey open the door
[Applause]
somebody doubles on the door you guys
use your magic on the front door juice
bag
you guys hey
somebody's baking brownies for the kkk
protective
the stick is ours die [ __ ]
i'm gonna beat you like your daddy
[Music]
i have to go to the bathroom
[Music]
i just we'll see if it works
[Music]
jesus christ nobody likes me
you'll pay for that
[Music]
[Music]
that
you're not waiting on me are you
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that was the most perfect throw i've
ever seen
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
uh
oh boy we won where's the king
he's over there he's hurt bad good thing
my medicine skills are plus four
we'll revive the wizard you guys get
upstairs
[Music]
we gotta get to the princess
that can't hurt
huh
wait a minute listen they're raping the
princess right now we have to bust in
[Applause]
there he's keeping a prisoner
[Music]
i think any parents are out of town
oh [ __ ]
woo
princess kinney how badly do they rape
you
i can't get through the door appears to
be enchanted so i can't turn the knob
you can't hold the doorknob bar that's
cheating yeah i can i have the stick of
truth which means i control the universe
and i say holding the doorknob is okay
ah can he do that he has a stick of
truth he could do what he wants
damn it there's got to be another way
into this room
hey let us up you're not getting up here
the ladder's up here with me
and i'm sure [ __ ] not coming down there
[Applause]
oh yeah oh those are some big old
bitties
man oh man
good job princess gone wild double d
buddy powers
[Applause]
[Music]
hmm
uh
[Music]
you've nowhere to run bart give me the
stick of truth take it from me if you
can
wizard king step forward now and fulfill
your death
and fulfill your day step forward now
and fulfill your day
step forward now and fulfill your day
step forward now and fulfill your day
your day step forward now and fulfill
your destiny
you are no match for a grand wizard the
stick belongs with us
and i shall use everybody power in my
class to keep it from you fine you want
to throw down brah
kick his ass douchebag who is douchebag
that sir douchebag to you
and he's about to teach you some manners
bird
foreign
[Music]
oh
huh
[Music]
[Music]
gently now put your mind to rest
[Music]
hey
me
don't forget to tip your serving winch
is that all you got
close your eyes no more thinking about
thinking about your troubles
sleep now with jesus
for you are blessed
oh you dirty wench
okay
[Music]
i hope you guys don't get angry
[Music]
i'm sorry
a box on me
wow what a terrific target
[Music]
i just we'll see if it works
oh boy
the stick is ours yay
[Music]
find his running shoes just kidding
so
ready to leave sir douchebag
the stick of truth is back where it
belongs
great job men douchebag for your heroic
deeds and valiant self-sacrifice at the
great battle of the giggling donkey
i hereby make you an official member of
the kingdom of koopa keep
welcome to the kkk
it's getting late the grand wizard needs
to go night night
okay mom thanks for pointing out bedtime
for everyone it's a school night hon
you and your little druid friends need
to we're not druids mom
we're [ __ ] warriors in wizards oh
that's it you're going to bed
the rest of you better get home too
[Music]
it's late han your parents will be
worried
now get ready for canada's
[Music]
there you are we've been looking all
over for you
you are grounded mister you march right
on home and go to sleep
now i want you to go to bed and think
about what you've done
um